hey everybody and welcome to talents
caper now this is a little game that was
developed by Oscar star Berg and
released an early access on Steam a few
days ago and according to Oscar himself
it's not really a game but more so just
a toy which I think I'll agree with
because there isn't really any objective
to this and there's not a lot of
gameplay either really the only thing
that you do here is you click on the
screen either the left mouse button to
build stuff and the right mouse button
to the lead stuff there are no options
and as you can see the UI is very simple
you just click and the game kind of
algorithmically builds stuff and so this
is why it's more of a toy than a game
you don't even have that much control
over what you're building it's just
really satisfying to build stuff and see
the animations happening and see
especially how the game algorithmically
tries to figure out what it is you're
trying to build and adds these details
and flourishes that just make everything
mix so charming with very little effort
so as you can see I just built two
building spaces here and it creates this
small bridge and then on top of this we
have a house now because I have the red
color selected here on the Left these
are really the only thing that you have
control over it builds a red house but
then the binoculars that you see over
here or the planter that's completely
random honestly I have no effect on
exactly what the game builds there and
as I build a little bit more you can see
the house stays the same but we get this
extra Street level on the the ground
floor and if I add another house block
then house becomes a bit bigger and add
it on top of this and we just have a
very small house with the tower and as
you can see it just already looks really
cool
and I think that's the one thing that I
like most about this game it just works
so well as a therapeutic little city
builder because you don't really have to
put much thought or effort into it
things just look charming by virtue of
the art style of the game and how well
it can figure out what you're trying to
build that said there are certain rules
though I think the first of which I've
already revealed that is if you build
anything in the water it always creates
this sort of base
level streetscape and you can build on
this but you'll still have this
foundation of gray stone so that's one
thing that you can't change another
thing is if you build towers the game
actually automatically creates spires so
as you can see over here because the
house here actually has this building on
the side it doesn't get a tower or
Aspire if you will
oh and we got some birds on the roof as
well that's really nice
once your city grows enough you'll get a
lot of birds flying about at the moment
there aren't any people or animations in
this sense but you do get birds but yeah
because this is a building block of two
blocks high we get a little spire here
and another thing that's interesting to
note is if you've got two of these next
to each other and you put a bridge in
the middle you get this and of course we
can also add something on top of that
and make it into this kind of Tower oh
oh and sometimes you get these really
interesting details that you can't
really you know necessarily think of but
that the game feels in like these these
lines with clothing on it here that's
really good but yeah I'm not going to do
too much else to this village another
thing that I just want to show off is if
you have two buildings of different
colors next to each other it does
separate the buildings so as you can see
we kind of get this the separate little
house here and if I put this here it's a
completely separate building which is
because this one connects to these
because it's on a different heights but
because this is just a separate
standalone little block it turns into it
turns into its own how it's fit if I do
this then everything connects again so
yeah these are some of the very basic
rules you don't have to think about it
too much
honestly I found that you can really
just click randomly at the screen and
things will eventually just look good in
this game but yeah these are the very
basic rules that we'll get to play
around with so without further ado I
just want to show off some of my own
projects before I move into the time
lapse where I try to build a city and at
the end of this video we'll see how it
all comes together so this city was
actually the first thing that I built in
this game once I got it and you can see
some of the basic rules at play we have
some standalone houses here at the
coastline with different colors and
in the middle this kind of Disneyland
castle sort of structure made out of
white walls and you'll notice that all
of these towers have spires on top of
them because they're all standalone
towers there's one more rule that I'm
gonna have to point out and that is well
there's actually two rules
I guess for one if you build up so above
the sea level but you do build sort of
between buildings or you build a wide
enough flat space the game does create
more streets so you can actually create
higher street levels and you can see the
little staircases that even connect them
over here so that's something that you
can play with and if you have a space
that is completely surrounded by
buildings the game creates a garden so
you can make city blocks with gardens
and trees in the middle of them so
honestly I really love all of the
greenery that you get it adds so much to
the to the charming vibe of this game
and just with these very basic rules you
can build lots of variety honestly
before I start the time lapse there's
one more thing I want to show off which
is a kind of a different thing I did I
suppose so on day two of my personal
townscape er adventures I decided to try
and build a modern city and this is
completely not something that you're
supposed to do with the game well if
there's anything that you're supposed to
do with it anyway it kind of does clash
with the style of the game but
considering you know the the context of
what I'm trying to do I think it works
out fairly acceptable this little
skyline was inspired by The Hague
especially because the Hague is very
post modernist architecture the only
thing I'll say is that the game does get
a little bit laggy when you have this
many squares in it which I was a little
bit surprised by given just how basic
the game is and it's a very small game
too but yeah all things considered it
was actually still really fun to build
this and it does showcase another really
interesting fact about the game and that
is that the grid of the game is very
irregular so if I turn on the grid view
you can see that you get all these very
curvy grids everywhere that you can
build on and you don't have any control
over this but it is something that is
really fun to play with especially
because these lines make it so that you
have spaces where five lines come
together
like for instance somewhere over here
but you also have spaces where three
lines come together and these different
grid spaces also create different shapes
of buildings so it's another one of
these variables that you may not have
much control over but it really helps to
make the art style of this game a lot
more appealing but yeah with that all
said I would like to move into the
time-lapse so without further ado let's
get started
so my inspiration for this build is
actually mostly the island kingdom of
Corona from the movie Tangled and I
really hope that YouTube isn't going to
be monetize me for name-dropping Corona
here I swear I'm talking about the
fictional island kingdom here not the
other thing that's going on that's
apparently getting people demonetised I
don't know if that's still happening but
regardless it's just a very unfortunate
coincidence I've never actually seen the
movie Tangled by the way I just really
liked the aesthetic of it and of Disney
movies in general and Disney castles
because that's the sort of vibe that I'm
getting from this game in general in
addition to I would say and I haven't
seen anybody else talk about this but I
really want to bring it up because
personally I've felt like this is really
the case this game reminds me so much of
some of the Studio Ghibli movies and I
really don't know if I'm alone in this
or not but I love Ghibli movies and
especially some of the European themed
ones really remind me of the art style
of this game I'm thinking about movies
like Howl's Moving Castle or especially
on the in the intro scene of Howl's
Moving Castle or Porco Rosso or
especially Kiki's Delivery Service some
of those aerial shots of the village
there which is actually inspired by
Stockholm really remind me of this game
as well which I'll be honest I'm totally
here for it because I love Ghibli movies
and just their whole aesthetic so it's
super cool I just all the time playing
this game I'm just reminded of these
kinds of movies but yeah for this build
I'm going for a somewhat larger island
with a village on it with Hills
gradually sloping toward the center with
a big castle in the center
in a sort of through Disney style
fashion having giant spires in the
middle so that you create this sort of
pyramid this curved pyramid shape to the
entire island where you have the biggest
towers in the center and they kind of
taper off in Heights as you go towards
the sides it's not super original I
guess it's even a bit similar to what
I've already built as my first build in
this game just on a bigger scale as I've
gotten more used to everything that's
available in the game but it's something
that I really wanted to try and see how
it works out I'm also very curious to
see how the time-lapse recording format
works out here because from what I've
heard from some other people is that
apparently the Creator intends to add
some sort of time-lapse mechanic into
the game itself at some point I'm not
sure if or how that's gonna happen at
any point in the future but for the time
being I just want to try my personal you
know time-lapse format of recording my
gameplay and just spinning it up and
getting back to it later so that's what
we're at right now and honestly I think
the game works pretty well for just
doing this as far as it goes for YouTube
videos anyway the camera doesn't have to
move around too much you can keep it
pretty still and the advantage is also
that I never really spent too much time
looking at menus and this is something
that I love about the game in general
because obviously you know normally when
you're playing with simulation games or
creative games you end up spending a lot
of your time just on the UI itself
moving through different pieces and
trying to select what you're trying to
build with which I think you don't
really realize until you get thrown into
a game like this where you don't have to
think about that at all you just click
on the screen and something that just
pops out to me right away is the fact
that I'm always just constantly building
stuff sometimes I'm deleting some stuff
too but more than when I would play City
skylines of planet coaster for instance
I'm just always placing stuff so things
go a lot quicker and it's it takes a lot
less effort and that's just something
that makes this so much more therapeutic
on top of just you know it being very
hard to make something that doesn't look
good
honestly in this game it's just such a
nice looking game that also I personally
struggle with the idea of how I'm ever
going to make more videos on this game
because I don't think there's you know
any particular kind of niche that I can
carve out for myself this video right
here is really just the show of what the
game is like what it's capable of and
yeah really just hammer on the fact that
this is just a toy that is really
therapeutic to play with but it's kind
of like doodling I think it's not really
you know it's super creative exercise
it's really just this little relaxing
toy to play with
but yeah aside from that it's it doesn't
really fit my channel even because it's
it's completely different in nature from
all the games that I usually play but
it's just too good and too fun not to
make some kind of video on it so here we
are I suppose and at the end of the day
cities are my thing even if they are
medieval looking cities in a very very
simple bare-bones
city builder like this one if we could
consider this a city builder which I
think I would I mean it's it's it's an
application where you build the city so
at its core definition I think it
applies but yeah it's something really
interesting to think about I don't know
it's just been keeping my mind occupied
for the last couple of days anyway but
yeah moving to the center of this whole
island here I finally built the castle
and this castle is just surrounded by
big walls with a sort of light grey
texture the light gray brownish textures
a and in the middle we have this big
white Hall I tried to model this after a
noise von Stein actually a little bit
which is a castle in the south of
Germany which also was the inspiration
for the original Disneyland castle so
there's this one big hall in the center
with a couple of towers around it
but it's not just a mess of random
spires it really has some book to it as
well which I think works out a lot
better than just having a bunch of
Towers randomly next to each other so
I'm pretty happy with how the castle
turned out it's also a little bit Game
of Thrones II I did look at some old
pictures of the Red Keep and things like
this in Game of Thrones just again an
idea for you know how the island could
be shaped out in general so that was
part of the inspiration as well but
aside from that I'm just filling in some
of the foothills here with some more
houses and that is basically it I added
one more Island over here I'm going to
add another Island on the other side of
the main island as well just to add
something to the sides but that's really
just about it and I also have to say
with the size of this this whole build
I'm almost running out of space like on
this side I'm actually running into the
world border and I'm also running into
the world border almost on the other
side space is very limited in this game
and you can't build huge sprawling
metropolis so that's something to keep
in mind but yeah with that said let's
take a quick look and how the final
products are inside all right so this is
the results of about two hours of work
so all things considered you can build
some pretty cool stuff in a very short
amount of time
but of course I also think this is not
really a game where the final product is
the focus it's more so just fun to build
stuff but yeah I at least want to
showcase it a little bit and I do like
how the the central castle does have a
bit of a body to it I figured out that
even though if you put roofs together
it normally creates a flat surface like
this one way to get around that is to
intersect it with higher sections of
roof like over here so I managed to get
a pointy roof on top of this whole
castle section bit here just by having
the tower kind of intersected and this
thing as well so that's something to
keep in mind there are always ways that
you can like sort of game this system
the Creator actually tweeted something
today there are nearly 500 different
sort of puzzle pieces that make up all
of the building blocks of this game
and the a I just kind of has to figure
out what kind of puzzle pieces to get
together depending on which building
blocks you're putting together but it
sometimes makes some really cool
combination so for instance I made these
little gateways just by putting some
blocks together it automatically makes
these slopes roofs going to the middle
here and then you just have this or
gable up front so obviously I don't know
all of the combinations of what building
blocks turn into when you put them
together yet but clearly there's
actually been some thought put into how
building blocks go together and what
you're trying to build and the game
really adjusts for a lot so one of my
favorite examples is actually the
entrance gates over here which is at the
sort of make-believe Harbor section with
a bunch of pigeons on the roof where you
could sell that on the bottom we have
these arches and it goes from iron
pillars into the stone arches for this
building piece here and then because
there's a separate building block which
actually is kind of unconnected to any
other building blocks but it does have
building blocks to the left and the
right underneath it it automatically
creates an arch over here as well and
then of course we have the spires on the
side so even though you only have one
building block and you just kind of
click everywhere you really get a large
variety of shapes and that is not even
to mention how the grid effects the
shape of things as well so for instance
on the side here and oh god the camera
is actually being a bit difficult with
me here because the world borders here
but on the side here we have a very big
writ space making this fire and a very
small and making this fire so you
definitely get a lot of variety that way
as well but even with that and with the
very uneven grid which is curvy at times
you also still have a lot of control
over how things look so altogether I
think it's really well balanced between
you know giving the player control over
how things look and taking the Krone the
control away from you to figure out how
to make things look as good as possible
I think the game strikes a really good
balance
and honestly I would personally
recommend this game if you're interested
in city building or creative games or
the kind of doodling game that this is
of course if you're interested in actual
gameplay I wouldn't recommend it this is
really all there is to it it's a very
simple game at least at the moment it's
still an early access of course so that
might also be a reason why you want to
wait with purchasing this game even if
you're interested in it
but I think for me my personal
conclusion is that this this little toy
if you will it doesn't do much but what
it does it does really well and for what
it is which is essentially just a
glorified doodling tool it's really
great the sound design is very
satisfying the way that everything comes
together and how the game figures out
what to turn buildings into is very
satisfying and the art style is just
really charming the colors of it all it
just works really well together and I
think the main thing is that with some
creative games it can be hard sometimes
to make something that you're happy with
sometimes you're just looking at what
you're building being very disappointed
by it and it's just demotivating this
game just makes it so easy to make nice
looking things and sure whatever you're
building doesn't have to look like this
it can be completely different as well
anyway but so far I've just noticed that
I can honestly just put down random
stuff and not really think about it too
much and still look back at it and think
hmm that's pretty neat and for that I
have to give this game props so that's
basically my conclusion I really like it
so far the game has a really great
foundation and I'm very curious to see
where it will go in the future if you're
already intrigued by this and you like
the kind of doodling too I would highly
recommend it otherwise wait for the
future and see what else gets added to
this if anything and I have to give a
final shout out to jazz and Mary from
City skylines who let me know about this
game's release as soon as it did and
because my friend Bob tweeted about this
and got likes for it I need to say don't
forget to Like and subscribe and click
that Bell to become part of the
notification squad I've never done calls
to action it it just feels strange I
feel like a weird person doing this but
I guess I have to do it now anyway this
one's for you Bob I guess I'll see you
guys in the next game or perhaps in the
future in another time scape or video
take care to stay safe and hope you have
a good day